Ravi de vous rencontrer
Il semble être un classement de 3 et le plus g
C'est comme livrer une vidéo ou une vidéo
Merci beaucoup
Je le fais comme si tu étais dehors
[musique]
je fais
vaudou
Quatre
Ouais
[musique]
avoir n
Ce vieux mechan oooh
Je l'ai eu de la personne qui me l'a donné 8 this
C'est un jour où tes yeux sont si pétillants
Ton ventre est si mignon
si mignon
personnage
je pense que c'est
il est parti
des gens
après tout
Il parait que pr n'a pas voulu savoir
peut être
[musique]
Ouais
avait
hoop dee whoa
vaudou
[musique]
cerceau
miu
Miauler
[musique]
millimètre
Porter
Ouais
Plutôt que de dire quelque chose comme ça parce que j'ai dépensé de l'argent
Eh bien, j'encourage une chose
Quelle est l'une des expressions ?
C'est vrai, la culture que nous avons jetée
En conséquence, nous de toutes sortes de Katya
Contenu qui vous divertira
Je sais que tu reviendras comme
Est-ce important finalement ?
N'exagérez pas votre vie, juste un peu de soutien
Je ne veux pas donner quelque chose que j'ai envie de faire
mais
[musique]
concernant
c'est ouvert
[musique]